AND ALSO THE SUSPECT.
>> GOOD MORNING.
DEPUTY CHIEF CRIS ROSS MAN WITH
THE MICHIGAN STATE POLICE PUBLIC
SAFETY.
AS YOU CAN TELL, IT THIS HAS
BEEN A LONG NIGHT FOR A LOT OF
US.
WE HAVE BEEN COMMITTED FROM THE
BEGINNING TO BEING AS
TRANSPARENT AND GETTING AS MUCH
INFORMATION OUT AS POSSIBLE, AND
WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO DO
THAT THROUGHOUT THE DAY AND AS
THIS INVESTIGATION MOVES
FORWARD.
I AM GOING TO START WITH A BRIEF
RECAP OF THE INCIDENT YESTERDAY.
THIS TRAGIC SITUATION UNFOLDED
SHORTLY BEFORE 8:30 P.M.
THE FIRST CALL THAT WE RECEIVED
WAS FROM BURKEY HALL, AN
ACADEMIC BUILDING ON THE
NORTHERN CAMPUS THAT BORDERS
DOWNTOWN EAST LANCING.
INITIAL CALLS REPORTED SHOTS
FIRED IN THAT BUILDING AND THERE
WAS AN ABSOLUTELY OVERWHELMING
POLICE RESPONSE TO THAT INITIAL
CALL.
WE HAD OFFICERS IN THAT BUILDING
WITHIN MINUTES.
AND IN THAT BUILDING THEY
ENCOUNTERED SEVERAL STUDENTS WHO
WERE INJURED.
WE CAN CONFIRM THAT TWO OF THE
DECEASED WERE IN BURKEY HALL.
ALONG WITH SEVERAL OF THE
VICTIMS.
WHILE THE OFFICERS WERE MANAGING
THAT SCENE AT BURKEY HALL, WE
BEGAN RECEIVING ADDITIONAL
REPORTS OF ANOTHER SHOOTING AT
THE MSU UNION BUILDING JUST TO
THE WEST OF BURKEY HALL RIGHT ON
THE CORNER OF ABBOTT AND GRAND
RIVER.
OFFICERS REDEPLOYED TO THAT
LOCATION WHERE WE DID LOCATE ONE
ADDITIONAL VICTIM.
WE HAVE THREE DECEASED AND FIVE
VICTIMS AT THE HOSPITAL.
WE CAN CONFIRM ALL THREE
DECEASED WERE MSU STUDENTS.
WE CAN ALSO CONFIRM AT THIS TIME
THAT ALL FIVE OF THE INJURED
VICTIMS AT THE HOSPITAL WERE
ALSO MSU STUDENTS.
WE WILL RELEASE THE NAMES OF
THOSE STUDENTS LATER TODAY.
ONCE WE WORK THROUGH SOME
NOTIFICATIONS AND MAKE SURE THAT
THE FAMILIES ARE AWARE THAT WE
ARE GOING TO RELEASE THOSE
NAMES.
THE SUSPECT IN THIS CASE WAS
LOCATED AT APPROXIMATELY
11:35 P.M. IN THE CITY OF
LANCING.
THE SUSPECT WAS LOCATED BY UNITS
THAT WERE ASSISTING IN LOOKING
FOR THAT SUSPECT AFTER THE
SHOOTINGS.
THE SUSPECT IS DECEASED DUE TO A
SELF-INFLICTED GUNSHOT WOUND AND
WE ARE PREPARED TO RELEASE THE
NAME OF THE PERSON WHO COMMITTED
THESE HOMICIDES AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE PREVIOUSLY CONFIRMED HE
WAS 43 YEARS OLD, A MALE.
HIS NAME IS ANTHONY, LAST NAME
IS McCRAY.
MCRAE.
ANTHONY DWYANECRAE.
ANTHONY DWYANE MCRAE.
WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU OR
COMMUNITY FOR THEIR HELP.
BECAUSE OF OUR QUICK RELEASE OF
THE PHOTOGRAPH FROM THE CAMPUS
SECURITY CAMERAS AND HELP FROM
OUR COMMUNITY, IT WAS A CALLER'S
TIP THAT LED LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
THAT SUSPECT IN THE CITY OF
LANCING.
WE CANNOT THANK THE PUBLIC AND
THE COMMUNITY AND THE PERSON WHO
CALLED IN THAT REPORT IN ENOUGH
FOR BEING OBSERVANT, FOR
FOLLOWING OUR MESSAGING, AND FOR
BEING VIGILANT IN CONTACTING US
IMMEDIATELY.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO SHARE
RESOURCES FOR THE MSU COMMUNITY
THROUGH OUR INSTITUTIONAL
WEBSITE AND OUR MSU POLICE AND
PUBLIC SAFETY SOCIAL MEDIA
PAGES.
WE KNOW THAT THIS NEWS MAY BE
DIFFICULT FOR THOSE WITHIN OUR
CAMPUS COMMUNITY AND BEYOND AND
IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
SOME -- IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT THE GRIEF THAT
SOME INDIVIDUALS MAY BE
EXPERIENCING IS NORMAL AND THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF WAYS IN WHICH
INDIVIDUALS CAN SEEK SUPPORT,
INCLUDING TALKING WITH FRIENDS,
FAMILY, AND COLLEAGUES TO
PROCESS THIS, AND TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF MANY OF THE
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE PROVIDED.
WE ARE PREPARED AT THIS POINT TO
TAKE SOME QUESTIONS.
WE WILL TURN IS OVER TO SPECIAL
AGENT IN CHARGE, JIM.
>> GOOD MORNING.
I AM THE SPECIAL AGENT IN CHARGE
OF THE FBI IN MICHIGAN.
FIRST OF ALL, OUR HEARTS GO OUT
TO ALL OF THE VICTIMS, THE
FAMILIES, THE STUDENTS IN THE
COMMUNITY.
THIS HAPPENS MUCH TOO OFTEN.
I'D LIKE TO THANK OUR PARTNERS
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT, CHIEF, ONCE
AGAIN, THANKS FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP.
JUST GREAT EXAMPLES OF
LEADERSHIP LAST NIGHT FROM ALL
OF THE AGENCIES THAT SHOWED UP
SHORT NOTICE AND SHOWED SELFLESS
SACRIFICE TO ATTEMPT TO
IDENTIFY, FIND THE SUBJECT AND
ELIMINATE THE THREAT.
LAST NIGHT WHEN THIS OCCURRED,
MANY AGENCIES ARRIVED ON SEASON.
THE FBI DEPLOYED AGENTS,
ANALYSTS, AND SPECIALTY TEAMS TO
HELP IN THE EFFORT TO HELP THE
VICTIMS AND
COMMUNITY AT LARGE TO COME
TOGETHER, AND WE WILL CONTINUE
WORKING IN THE FUTURE HAND IN
HAND TO MITIGATE THESE THREATS
AND TRY TO MAKE MICHIGAN AS SAFE
A PLACE AS WE CAN FOR FAMILIES.
THANK YOU.
>> WE ARE PREPARED TO TAKE SOME
QUESTIONS.
THIS IS STILL FLUID, STILL
ONGOING.
THERE ARE STILL CRIME SCENES
BEING PROCESSED.
AND WE STILL ARE IN THE PROCESS
OF PUTTING TOGETHER THE PIECES
TO TRY TO SOLVE -- TO TRY TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT HAPPENED AND WHY
IT MAY HAVE HAPPENED.
SO WE'RE STILL WORKING THROUGH
THAT.
SO WE WILL GO AHEAD AND TAKE
SOME QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME.
>> WERE SEVEN --
>> HOLD ON.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> THANK YOU.
THERE WAS A LARGE POLICE
PRESENCE ON CRESTON AVENUE IN
LANCING.
WAS THAT THE SUSPECT'S HOME?
>> SO I CAN'T CONFIRM THE ACTUAL
LOCATION OR ADDRESS.
WE ARE AWARE THAT THERE WAS A
SEARCH WARRANT EXECUTED ON A
RESIDENCE THAT WAS CONNECTED TO
THE SUSPECT IN THIS CASE.
WE ARE NOT PREPARED SHARE THAT
SPECIFIC LOCATION AT THIS POINT.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY INFORMATION
ON THE FIREARM AND WHETHER IT
WAS REGISTERED TO THE INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS SUSPECTED OF USING IT?
>> AT THIS POINT WE HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON THE
ACTUAL WEAPON USED IN THE
INCIDENT.
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO PROCESS AND LOOK AT
TODAY AS PART OF OUR
INVESTIGATION.
>> DID YOU RECOVER THE WEAPON?
>> WE DID RECOVER -- WE DID
RECOVER A WEAPON, YES.
>> SEVEN OF THE EIGHT VICTIMS
ARE BERKEY HALL, THE EIGHTH AT
THE UNION AND THE UNION VICTIM
PASSED AWAY.
IS THAT CORRECT?
>> THERE WERE TWO OF THE VICTIMS
FROM BERKEY HALL ARE DECEASED.
ONE VICTIM FROM THE UNION IS
DECEASED.
THERE ARE FIVE ADDITIONAL
VICTIMS THAT ARE AT SPARROW
HOSPITAL.
I CANNOT CONFIRM WHERE ALL FIVE
OF THOSE VICTIMS, WHICH BUILDING
THEY WERE IN.
I BELIEVE MOST OF THEM WERE FROM
BERKEY HALL.
I CAN'T CONFIRM THAT.
>> YES?
>> I UNDERSTAND THE FIRST -- YOU
SAID OFFICERS ARRIVED SHORTLY
AFTER THE CALL.
THE SECOND BUILDING, CAN YOU
DESCRIBE THE TAME TABLE?
OFFICERS WERE [ INAUDIBLE ].
>> THE MSU UNION IS WITHIN VERY
CLOSE PROXIMITY TO BERKEY HALL,
WITHIN WALKING DISTANCE.
I WOULD DESCRIBE IT AS LESS THAN
A BLOCK TO THE WEST OF BERKEY
HALL.
ALL INDICATIONS AT THIS POINT,
POINT TO THE FACT THAT THE
SUSPECT EXITED BERKY HALL AND
WALKED OVER TO THE MSU UNION.
WHEN THOSE CALLS INITIALLY
STARTED COMING IN FROM THE
UNION, WE WERE ABLE TO QUICKLY
REDEPLOY RESOURCES TO THE UNION
AND THE SUSPECT QUICKLY FLED
THAT BUILDING.
HE WAS NOT IN THE BUILDING FOR
THAT LONG.
>> WHEN YOU SAY REDEPLOYED, HOW
MUCH OF A TIMETABLE?
>> I CAN'T GET INTO THE
SPECIFICS ON THE TIMEFRAME RIGHT
NOW, BUT THAT WILL BE PART OF
THE INVESTIGATION THAT WE WILL
LOOK AS IS THE TIME BETWEEN
THOSE TWO INCIDENTS.
>> HAS THE SUSPECT HAD PREVIOUS
INTERACTION WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT?
>> THAT'S PART OF OUR
INVESTIGATION TODAY IS TO LOOK
AT THE SUSPECT, HIS BACKGROUND,
HIS HISTORY.
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT ARE
OCCURRING WITH OUR STATE AND
FEDERAL PARTNERS RIGHT NOW WHO
HAVE REALLY TAKEN THE LEAD ON
HELPING US WITH IDENTIFYING THE
SUSPECT, ESPECIALLY SINCE THAT
INCIDENT DID OCCUR OFF CAMPUS.
BUT THOSE ARE THINGS THAT WE ARE
LOOKING AT TODAY AND THOSE WILL
BE INTEGRAL TO THE
INVESTIGATION.
>> CAN YOU SHED ANY LIGHT AS TO
THE WHY, WHY THIS HAPPENED?
WHAT HIS MOTIVE WAS?
WHY HE CHOSE MICHIGAN STATE?
>> WE HAD THE SAME QUESTION LAST
NIGHT AND WE HAVE THE SAME
ANSWER THIS MORNING.
WE HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO IDEA WHAT
THE MOTIVE WAS AT THIS POINT.
WE CAN CONFIRM THAT THE
43-YEAR-OLD SUSPECT HAD NO
AFFILIATION TO THE UNIVERSITY.
HE WAS NOT A STUDENT, FACULTY,
STAFF.
CURRENT OR PREVIOUS.
SO THAT'S AN UNKNOWN RIGHT NOW.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND, IS WHY THIS INCIDENT